qu'est ce que la médiocratie ça c'est la
grosse question la médiocratie est un
terme qui désigne un régime puis
contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire ne
nivelle pas tellement par le bas que par
le moyen la médiocrité envoie ce qui est
moyen et la médiocratie renvoie un ordre
qui nivelle par le moyen par des
protocoles des standards des formes des
conformismes divers dans des milieux
tels que le travail
le loisir la politique ainsi de suite
donc nivelé par le moyen que ce que
c'est cela veut dire exiger des acteurs
sociaux où qu'ils soient qu'ils fassent
preuve d'un certain niveau de compétence
mais pas trop leur savoir dire bonjour
la bonne personne la bonne façon de
remplir le formulaire faire fonctionner
le photocopieur mais ne pas avoir trop
d'idées de bonnes idées initiative
morale principe dans vie le désir qu'a
libre et éclairé les choses comme on le
fait faire comme ils font ce qu'ils
veulent une idée plus précise de ce que
peut être la médiocratie
on peut relire la mort d'ivan illitch de
dole story
au moment